this is the grand Ethiopian Renaissance
dam
one of Africa's biggest infrastructure
projects 4.7 billion dollar giant
hydroelectric dam a monster of concrete
and steel the government believes it's
going to revive the economy but Egypt
worries this might come at its own
expense
mahat this year the VMS semi Atmos the
hyah
Elisha negotiations over the dams
operations have dragged on for years
with neighbouring Sudan caught in the
feud and both Egypt and Ethiopia hinting
at possible military action over the
project attempts to reach a final
comprehensive deal have ended in
deadlock with many key questions still
open so why is it so hard to settle the
dispute over the Nile let us unpack that
for you
[Music]
the employees of the world's longest
river the Nile can hardly be overstated
it's essential for the 280 million
people living along its banks in the
Nile Basin it runs through 11 countries
but Ethiopia's plans on the Nile are
being watched
especially closely in Egypt and Sudan
and to understand why let's take a look
at how the river flows the Niles main
source is in Ethiopia at Lake Tana water
flows towards Sudan and joins the rivers
other tributary at Sudan's capital
Khartoum before heading downstream to
Egypt the grand Ethiopian Renaissance
dam pergurt for short is being built
here on the border with Sudan
near the Nile source the dam would catch
water in its massive reservoir whose
surface area is larger than that of
Greater London the water is then
harnessed to generate electricity simply
put the new dam gives Ethiopia
considerable control over how much water
flows downstream and the stakes are
immensely high for all parties involved
yo Pia wants the dam to supercharge its
economy as the country's population and
ambitions grow it could be part of
Ethiopia's transformation it does
provide sufficient power for all sorts
of future investment particularly in
manufacturing which is an area that
Ethiopia has been trying to move into
increasingly
either presenting itself as a site for a
labor-intensive manufacturing because
ultimately you know Ethiopia has as very
cheap labour also has quite cheap power
it could have a huge impact on everyday
Ethiopians prospects
roughly 65% of the country is not
connected to the power grid something
the government wants to change if things
go as planned energy from the dam could
also more than double Ethiopia's current
output fulfilling its needs and making
it an exporter with Al each other's root
system known internationally they are
thoroughly meanwhile Kyra says the dam
can operate under one condition that
Egypt is not harmed the country is home
to almost 100 million people who depend
on the Nile for a 90% of their
freshwater supply one fear is that
Ethiopia will leave too much water in
its reservoirs during periods of drought
endangering the flow downstream that
could leave Egypt's farmers unable to
irrigate their lands causing major food
losses and all this as the effects of a
warming climate have already strained
Egyptian agriculture any two percent
drop of water affects 1 million people
so it's really the more impoverished
categories and the farmers I think that
will be effective and where does all of
this leave Sudan it's caught quite
literally in the middle of things so
that mean a new man I would Brian was
actually Marathi toffee masala had to be
similar between the Potala - I had a CPA
Hamiltonian the effects for Sudan seemed
mixed what fear is that GERD could
jeopardize the operations of Sudan's own
dams on the Nile
however Sudan also sees an opportunity
to get cheap energy from Ethiopia thanks
to GERD and it could regulate water
flows but if sometimes caused flooding
and beyond economic interests
negotiations around the dam I've also
been marred by distrust in 2013 a
meeting broadcast live between then
Egyptian president Mohamed Morsi and
political advisors showed one of them
suggesting phone
internal conflict to distract Ethiopia
from building the dam defeated obscenity
we evita Cyril Alcala while ftfs Dominic
monetary collapse agaric chiefly the
pizzelle like a tiger animals even
recently Ethiopia accused Egypt of
sponsoring cyberattacks to disrupt the
project and Ethiopia has repeatedly
threatened to unilaterally start filling
the dams reservoir with or without an
agreement with Egypt and Sudan the
dispute over the Nile is also
complicated by issues with deeper roots
like history and culture the Deb has
reignited an age-old debate about who
exactly owns the Nile so it's been its
denials vital role in in Egypt's
civilization and history which continues
until this day which makes this such a
seismic issue ancient Egyptians revered
it and called it a gift of the gods and
this view of the Nile still resonates
today the nada de wen Lieh deep Tiki the
aluminum na min NF is silly today the
Nile occupies a prominent place an
Egyptian contemporary culture sometimes
featuring and songs for kids
[Music]
but of course Egyptians aren't along
there
Ethiopians called the Niles main
tributary ABAI and Ethiopian culture
also has an enduring attachment to it
[Music]
and Ethiopia also sees this project is
overcoming what it perceives as historic
injustice relating to not being able to
use the Nile waters for its development
because of historic treaties and other
claims of Egyptian effectively
that's right back to 1929 Britain has
been a colonial power in Africa and
signed a treaty with Egypt granting
Cairo the right to veto projects higher
up the Nile that would affect its water
share
[Music]
19:59 brought another key agreement this
time between Egypt and Sudan
it gave Egypt the right to 55 billion
cubic meters of Nile water a year and
Sudan eighteen point five billion cubic
meters per year Ethiopia was not
consulted and in 1970 Egypt finished
building its own massive dam which
helped control flooding and utilize the
Nile to boost its economy the feeling of
historical injustice on the site of
Ethiopia and historical attachment on
the site of Egypt have made any talks on
sharing the Nile harder therefore it's
not looking to make compromises and
concessions on this project and instead
it's looking for the downstream
countries to do so
Egypt on the other hand sees you know
the Nile is a vital source of water
reject and it has concerns about this
project and the way Ethiopia has has
gone about it even with a final deal on
the dam talks and further cooperation
will be necessary in the years ahead
there are more project slated for the
future along the Nile raising further
questions about the division of
resources and the effects of climate
change and growing populations mean
water could be an increasingly scarce
resource what needs to happen here is
that you know despite this very
torturous
process and the disappointment and
disillusion of the parties for various
reasons the only option here is to
return to the negotiating table and it's
very important for Sudan and Egypt that
they are working with Ethiopia that they
can trust Ethiopia that Ethiopia will
look after their interests as these
quite vulnerable downstream countries
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
edition of unpacked what we're trying to
do with the series is break down
complicated stories that shape our world
and we'd love to hear from you for more
ideas so if there's a particular topic
you'd like us to dive into let us know
in the comments section and maybe it'll
be the topic of our next video